là où ce que vous m'entendez qu'est ce
que le som marche audience que le second
passe bien ce que vous pouvez commenter
me dire si le son passe bien je le situe
t ça j'arrive j'arrive je suis juste en
train de tuer savoir espérant que le som
marche bien vous faire des maths
les grosses mat ok cool
entre temps des leçons les biens une
fois que j'ai fait ça le son saturé
j'espère qu'ils saturent pas dire coucou
au smat salle louis cros mat bien sale
aujourd'hui me faire des trucs ça va
être donc le but d aujourd'hui ça va
être de prouver que va prouver le terme
classique fin des tournois importants à
une machine learning qui est de dire que
c'était la descente de gradient
stochastique marche donc la descente de
gradient stochastique c'est vraiment
l'algorithme le plus utilisé en machine
learning ses débuts raisons de penser
que c'est l'algorithme qui va qui va
faire tout être utilisé dans le futur
également et casser le cadre vraiment
plus classique du matching running et un
théorème particulier dans ce cadre qui
prouve que le machine learning en gros
ça c'était avant quelques garanties et
paul ricard sur vos sites sur les murs
de mon appartement
c'est en cela que ça va être un vrai de
beautiful mind c'est un peu n'importe
quoi c'est du grand n'importe quoi alors
et donc le théorème principal
j'expliquerai bien plus après mais a
donc on va supposer
et puis j'ai rien préparé aussi c'est je
suis pas sûr que ça va marcher à ce que
je vais dire mais je sais que ça va
marcher
donc m neterra lui dis donc ce qu'il
veut c'est que on a une fonction
elle va appeler un sudoku l'osce
fonctionnent elles
voici une voix je rapproche peu à peu
plus tard
donc elle qui fonctionne donc 2 rbds et
non r moi supposé maintenant yards plus
donc ça reste posée que l est une
fonction non positives et d'autres
hypothèses va se poser que l ai rappelé
à elle souffre elle lisse l'une en
france donc
j'expliquerai plus tard mais en gros ça
veut dire que le gradient la sienne 2 x
fin de l an x
partout entre mois l identité et l
identité voilà et je suppose également
que ça va durer très longtemps donc pour
aller voir quels sont les autres ces
hypothèses à faire donc elle lisse
je veux oublier des hypothèses à tous
les coups ça arrive tout le temps
une des autres hypothèses en tout cas
c'est que maintenant on estime qu'une
estimation de l du gradient de noël donc
une estimation qui va me permettre de
dire que si je prends l'espérance un
estimateur j'ai voulu monter ça chante
et à six il s'agit un peu une fonction
j'ai que je peux appeler et quand je
l'appelle en moyenne ça me donne bon
gradient donc le gradient de l etat ce
avec les peurs avec nous je m'étais tas
explique une de ces notations et je vais
aussi supposer que c'est estimateur donc
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle noguez sénart
qui sort le gradient en moyenne et j'ai
aussi supposer que si je fais j'ai moins
gradient de penn state of shock 70
l'espérance dessau carré ça ça va être
bornes on simule carré variance fini
dans l'estimation donc ça non si on
était un petit peu
et donc le théorème j'oublie peut-être
des hypothèses en tout cas le théorème
c'est que donc c'est ici je prends la
suite qu'elle ait fini par un état zéro
partenon r&d va poser des tas t + 1 est
égal à tat mois - il t'a j'étais donc à
chaque étape en fait on fait un pas de
gradient décès de diminuer où on va dans
le sens du gradient et on suppose que le
gt ainsi obtenues
ça chantait tacle et donc quelles que
soient ses satisfasse à vous appeler
conditions appelé 1 2 3 4
donc on va supposer que 3 et 4 sont
vérifiées donc si on a un état zéro qui
est défini comme ça alors le théorème
nous dit que si je prends
j'ai hésité entre plusieurs versions
approuvées le constater ici qui
dépendent de thé était athée il ya
plusieurs versions va prendre celle là
un peu plus chiante à écrire est
possible et c'est pas très beau à hitler
et ben ouais le gardon qui vous qu'il
existe il existe une façon
le tirer et à chapeau t ou hasard en
fait en particulier parmi les petites a1
et a2 et acheter alors qu'on peut il est
ce une façon de tirer une des valeurs
aux arts tels que l'espérance du
gradient qu radio en tt shop aux doutes
et aux normes de référence des normes
envers 0 ça c'est le théorème du de vue
machine horning donc on se rapprocher un
peu la caméra petit problème de file
bah ça c'est un terrain assez classique
en machine learning ces symptômes assez
classique en machine learning
j'espère je n'ai pas oublié d'hypothèses
mais en gros ça à face pendant qu'on
fait du machine learning c'est que fait
ce qu'on appelle la descente de gradient
donc ça c'est l'équation de descente de
gradient et donc à chaque étape en fait
de l'algorithme on va mettre à jour un
peu nos paramètres sites et de les
ajuster pour faire moins d'erreurs elle
c'est une fonction d'erreurs en fait et
on veut minimiser rl on le perd le moins
d'erreurs possible du coup on fait une
descente de loin le gradient le truc
c'est que souvent le gradient on peut
pas le calcul exactement parce que
typiquement faudrait prendre la moyenne
sur toutes les données imaginables et
prennent c'est qu'on a été les utilisons
et des jeux de données fini et du coup
on a juste un estimateur qui peut être
biaisé acquis qui est rare mêlant récit
bascule et non biaisée par contre qu'il
est parfois donne pas forcément un
résultat et on suppose que les variants
c'est fini et en faisant tout ça donc
normalement on peut converger ces algues
hoyt de convergence qui dit qu en gros
là le point vers lequel on va c'est un
point où le gradient nuls hors grade est
égal à zéro c'est pas forcément ça va
pas vraiment dire ni mise l'erreur
gradient égal 0 ça peut être en fait
idéalement on va voir un truc comme ça
là le gradient ça c'est la fonction de
coo l2 et à sa cp tu as également on
veut arriver un point ici comme ça ou
c'est un minimum du coup ça c'est ça
c'est le bon gars mais ce qui est
possible c'est qu'on arrive au fait à
obtenir un truc un peu inverse ne fait
pas ça est assez improbable mais bon on
pourrait techniquement arrivé un truc
comme ça fait en dimension supérieure on
risque d'avoir sur tout ce qu'on appelle
un point tel qu'un procès c'est à dire
que second étage et ont fait plusieurs
directions pour tétouan l2t pas ici
serait un minimum selon certaines
directions un maximum cinq ans de
direction puis m'ont peut avoir des
trucs aussi un peu comme ça radiant est
égal à zéro fonds string s'occupe par
exemple ok ok donc ça ça c'est un truc
assez classique comme machine learning
pourrait montrer la démonstration de ça
et ça serait ça serait déjà cool mais
aujourd'hui je vais me lancer un défi un
peu inhabituel va se lancer un défi un
peu inhabituel est assez difficile
puisque je vais essayer de prouver ça
mais aux mathématiques constructive
donc il sait pas si vous savez ce que
sont les maths constructive dans le jet
met donc les mathématiques constructive
l'idée c'est que on ne s'autorise que
des fonctions que l'on peut calculer et
que les objets qui composent calculé
qu'on peut construire et malheureusement
ça ça ça la preuve classique de sa ne
s'appuie pas sur les modes constructifs
plupart des maths ne sont pas telles
qu'elles sont faites aujourd'hui ne sont
pas constructives et en fait c'est un
énorme défi que d'essayer de faire tout
ça en maths constructive alors là je
pense qu'on est même parti pour des
heures et des heures
je sais pas combien de temps ça va
prendre ça peut-être prendre plusieurs
jours pour réussir à démontrer ça en est
constructive
je suis même pas sûr de savoir comment
faire j'ai quelques idées j'ai un peu
réfléchi mais je suis pas sûr que ça va
marcher
donc c'est un peu une aventure va y
avoir des hauts et des bas et il espère
que l'ensemble du mur effacé effacer
plusieurs folle va suffire mais c'est si
loin d'être gagné je pense pas qu'il
aura cède pas sur le mur ok avec ça
c'est un peu le théaux a va démontrer
voilà pourquoi est-ce que c'est
compliqué de faire des maths
constructive le problème c'est que les
maths constructive en fait pour faire
des maths constructive et sentent ici
ok le la difficulté de faire des maths
constructif c'est que les nombres réels
auxquels on pense donc les nombreux à l
tels que vous avez appris à l'école ne
sont pas des nombres constructif
oui on a déjà parlé de l'exemple de
katyn dans la série sur la forme de
belize et qui avait pas de l'algorithme
par exemple pour donner des
approximations du nombre de check in
au fait les inventions de l'algorithme
mixé par alan turing est en fait dans
son article de 1936 il en fait
construire un nombre qui existent sont
les maths classique mais qui n'est pas
constructible c'est là qu'il n'ya pas
d'algorithmes capable de donner des de
calculer son nombre alors calculer un
nombre on pourrait dire c'est un peu
bizarre parce que priorité des décimales
alors battre constructive en fait on
peut dire par exemple si je prends le
nombre un tiers égal à 0,3 3 3 3
et ainsi de suite ça c'est un nombre qui
a priori à une infinité de décimales
mais il est en fait très constructif
pourquoi parce que comme c'est décimales
se répète
il existe un algorithme très simple qui
calcule la décimale de ce nombre en
particulier si je veux une approximation
de un tiers à 5 décimales très bas j'ai
un algorithme qui va juste sortir 0,3 à
3 3 à 3 c'est très simple en gros il
valait zéro virgule et puis après ils
rajoutent aux drones de 3 que le nombre
de frais proxima sion que l'on doit donc
en fait en maths constructive
il ya une définition assez naturelle
d'un nombre réel donc de le punir
r nous ensemble dénombré l on va voir
définition un peu compliqué donc est en
fait ça va être donc ça est un ensemble
de fonctions quand je lis car vous
l'écrire en entier c'est l'ensemble des
fonctions je vais les appeler
donc c'est l'ensemble doit appeler ça
des fonctions qu x qui prennent un
nombre rationnelle positif non tenues
strictes et qui donne un autre nom vaut
rationnelle qui va être un peu
l'approximation du nombre x
donc on veut que lorsque l'on donne
accueilli x un degré de précision donc
typiquement qu x2 epsilon ça va être une
approximation 2x haïti nos rêves
alors donc typiquement donne envie de
dire que x 2 epsilon dans l'île le dire
qu x2 epsilon doit être à une distance
au plus deux epci l'aune du x ça s'est
un peu l'intuition qu'on a envie
d'écrire
c'est sûr qu'on les prem's et que x est
pas encore défini parce qu'on veut
définir le nombre réel est donc l'astuce
c'est de définir en fait des suites de
kochi donc l'idée c'est que si on a ça
avoir forcément tous les éléments
suivants de la suite doit aussi à +2 et
pylônes opus de cette approximation
donc ça ça veut dire en fait que on veut
que si on fait donc pour tout epsilon et
delta positif donc dorénavant quand
j'écris un traitement positif ça
sous-entend en fait
appartenant à cupules ccd rational
strictement positif moi parce que les
rationnels oublie de dire mais eux sont
parfaitement construit multifonds suffit
de choisir numérateur dominateur puis
lors comme ledesma se répète c'est un
sentiment sans que c'est que c'est
constructif et met donc la lame annonce
qu'on veut c'est que les surfaces de sa
forme les suites de
de kochi et du coup pour ça il faut que
m'a demandée c'est que q x2 epsilon
moins que x des deltas ça va être
inférieure à epsilon plus d'élèves c'est
la commission qu'on va poser c'est que
si on prend des pylônes et d'état très
petit on a deux appréciations qui sont
forcément très proches l'une de l'autre
ok donc ça s'arrête l'ensemble de
nombreux réel donc un nombre aurait elle
finalement ça va être une fonction qui
donne des approximations du nombre réel
et si j'arrive à construire ça j'arrive
à pension un nombre varié ok je pense
que jusque là c'est bon c'est très clair
ça marche bien on va peut-être une
différence par rapport aux suites de
kochi c'est que là si on le jeu donne
epsilon je suis capable d'être prouvé
une approximation près si vous prenez la
définition des suites de la cauchie
classique vous avez apprise à l'école
notre mode super en première année
d'université
en fait ça va être une définition non
constructif des suites de kochi puisque
les studios chic classique en ce cas on
n'est pas capable de donner même si on
sait que c'est une suite de coaching
n'est pas capable de dire de données
d'approximations et 6ème près bon bref
donc ça c'est une mort et lcp que
maintenant on va falloir définir les
nombreux les fonctions de r dans l'air
donc fonction de r dentaire ça va
ressembler à quoi donc
donc si donc supposons que f sur une
fonction de herde bancaire alors ça veut
dire que alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est à dire que si je donne à f
donc un élément de m on a vu que c'est
[Applaudissements]
une fonction qu x donc il faut imaginer
que f
en fait ça va prendre en compte
quid donc est en fait son entrée il
avait un programme une fonction
fonctionne qu x1 on peut imaginer ça
c'est un programme on lui donne une
approximation un nombre rationnels ils
sortent d'une approximation rationnelle
donc f lui il va dépendre d'un dindon 28
x
donc si je vois la plitique sont loin je
l'appelais saïx simplement je me
trimballe ce q q c'était pauvre
rationnelle imx d'epsilon tel état est
même plutôt qui crie ça comme ça je
l'écris en dénominateur exceptionne
dextérité
on sait plus clair comme ça
là c'était un puissions je la laissais
ok donc maintenant si je prends une
fonction af on envie de dire pouvoir
calculer ce qu'on veut pouvoir calculer
en cf2 x et epsilon pourquoi parce que
si elle de vix après ça va être un
nombre réel mais ce qu'on veut pour
avoir nous reste
être capable de donner des aides
d'approximations epsilon près de ce
nombre réel donc f 2 x ce qui nous
intéressait en fait pour définir h il va
nous falloir définir dfx epsilon ou f2
xlpe silva est une approximation de f
abstrait et ce qu'on veut bien sûr c'est
que f2i x - et pilonnent moins de x
delta soit inférieure affectionne plus
delta alors ces notions avec un peu
lourde
j'ai lu un bouquin qui a fait ça qui est
un bouquet en moto pelli taipei théorie
je parle dans la série sont infinies il
utilise la notation est un proxy donc la
loppsi est la différence entre x epsilon
et xla delta est inférieure à une puce
delta on va écrire ça du coup ce qu'on
veut c'est l'ensemble des fonctions de
rdr finalement ça va être
l'ensemble des fdf donc tels que on a ça
pour tout et pilonnés pour totalité pour
toutes xe où x c'est un nombre réel et
epsilon et dalida sont entrés terrain
positif
ok ok donc l'une des grosses difficultés
maintenant c'est qu'il va falloir
définir toute l'analyse en fait à partir
de somme alors comment est-ce qu'on
définit l'analyse à partir de 5 ans
qu'on a on a ça je voudrais aussi de
notation ont fait 6 approximations l
etat est en fait finalement c'est un
programme qui prend un programme et un
rationnel et une histoire non rationnel
et il faut qu'en plus on met sa garantie
l'esa ok
on va essayer définir la limite d'une
fonction ok ça c'est des définitions je
vais mettre un triplé galles pour dire
que ces définitions
tlf et essayer de faire un exemple je
sais d exemple je vais essayer de
définir la fonction iq scala et
finissent m'ont appelé à des knicks est
égal à x carey a deux qui s'étaient
guère les cas on veut dire que c'est une
fonction bien définie
mais il faut vérifier que c'est bien et
fine en ce sens cc c'est moins évident
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut définir
des axes carré alors c'est à dire que or
ce qu'il nous faut c'est si on donne à
epsilon lipsynch positif et x1 nombre
réel est ce qu'on veut maintenant
calculer c'est une approximation de f2 x
alps il sommes prêts donc c'est que x on
n'a pas à priori d'une approximation
psylo de près je dispose est telle qu'on
va essayer de donc pour tout délit
terrain positif en tout cas là on sait
que x delta activement il est
c'est moins vrai dire un delta venu pour
l'instant x deltae x nous on sait que
c'est un tel talent plus nue donc si je
regarde donc ça servira dire que x delta
- x nus étaient inférieures ou égales à
des tâches plus nuls ok ben moi ce qui
m'intéresse a déjà instruit xl takhar et
xmpp carrés à elle pour avoir ça ce que
je veux c'est étudié x delicta carré - x
tenu du fort carré comme ans que je fais
ça intuitivement j'aurais envie de dire
que donc ça on sait que c'est x delta -
une tenue voire inspector + 6 nuls
[Musique]
ok en fait je vais pas définir je faire
ok ok donc en fait pour faire ça du coup
ce que je vais faire c'est que je veux
d'abord regarder une approximation à un
prêt de x ce que je sais c'est un peu
une parenthèse à ce sujet des calculs
pour le premier problème
donc on va regarder x1
pour avoir un ordre de grandeur de ça
donc ça va ça c'est intuitivement
c'était que ça va être inférieure à six
mines deux fois inférieur à 2 x x du max
max en trois duels
max delta x nu
et en fait donc c'est inférieur
également particulière
ouais ça c'est inférieur à gala x keita
tout en te vois x lta
plus de sens
ok c'est pas mal ça veut dire que ça va
être du coût inférieur ou égal à telle
table plus nue choix de sa dette à
l'état a plus nulle hockey parce que
c'est pas mal ça c'est pas mal parce que
ok sépare donc les marges à prendre
telle taille égale 2 on va essayer de
faire si delta ilnu sont plus petits que
te que un tchadien ça c'est le plus
petit que 1 c'est pas facile en données
finir ça
l'excellent site
comment comment je fais ce qu'on ne l'a
dit c'est que ça je peux ce que je veux
dire que c'est plus petit que x ouais je
pense qu'on harlem je vais inviter un
premier même si toi là toute la
difficulté à j'ai toujours pas de
définition de x l'epsilon du coup la
shoah tous en train de travailler sur
l'intuition pour pouvoir trouver la
bonne valeur de x epsilon je vous trouve
intuitivement comment comment est-ce
qu'on calcule une approximation
[Musique]
plus raisonnée graphiquement mais si on
suppose qu x il a c'est à dire que les
prochains six mois est-ce que je
conversais x car est typiquement avoir
valeur champix ça c'est qu'elle est rare
que l'on fait là
[Musique]
un public plus jeune
avec de nouvelles de base naik 6 6 x
caristie et si j'ai une incertitude sur
x isti on a dû exploser ou moins s'ils
donnent c'est ça au carré on dira que
c'est du fedict thierry plus ou moins 2
x epsilon je vous ai préparé sa
supérieure ou égale à t-elle tôt pour
faire ça du coup if que epsilon soit
plus petits
[Musique]
2 x + 1 nintendo
ok ok je pense que je voulais peut-être
parce qu'on a essayé de faire c'est
considérer
[Musique]
les souvenirs il faut définir f2i
exceptionne sa première étape donc je
vais les finir
eve 2 x epsilon comme étant xts epsilon
xx e
epsilon qui va est divisé par 2 x en
plus deux coups car et c'est un sens a
donc là l'idée c'est que je prends
l'approximation 2x à epsilon / 2x plus
fort plus 2 arabe seul exemple +2 et je
prends tout ça au carré ok donc si je
calcule f 2 x et si lon - fbx delta
[Musique]
je vais recevoir ici aussi
donc si je regarde un de xm si lon fdx
delta égale à 6 epsilon / 2 x 1 2 ap 2 -
x qu'elle t'a dit parle de x1 plus de
hockey au carré cé carré à chaque fois
et donc ça on a vu à travers cette
inégalité segal ax6 la lui divisé par 2
x tu as juste deux mois deux fois xts
ypsilon / 2,8 de plus elle est à 2x plus
[Musique]
assurée
ok alors ce que je sais maintenant c'est
que ça par définition de x epsilon c'est
inférieur ou égal à la somme des 2
epsilon plus delta / 2 x 1 et la suisse
peine c'est ce que ça va marcher sa part
ça ce que je sais c'est que c'est
inférieur à 2,2 pour le max d2 le max
entre x l'ypsilon / 2 x 1 + 2 et x /
sont de hockey
donc si
[Musique]
je vais avoir besoin d ipsen perd mon
petit dieu
[Musique]
ok on va se poser on va dire ou un ch'ti
epsilon et que petit que ce que l'on
après techniquement sa retraite et a
besoin d'eux surtout qu il a juste
besoin de refaire voilà en fait on
pourrait juste à voir mines entre
epsilon b sa bombe a alors vous voyez
plus alors deux fois le max de sa esta
et se poser ici que avec epsilon et d'un
casque en plus petit que hors du coup
ici et si ça c'est vraiment l'un 10 à
400 soit rentable et que ça donc c'est
un fait rare fois
mines sessad internet ça que ses
bouillants celles administrées mines du
coup vous regardez justin des termes je
regardais les premiers sont exposées
ainsi optionné petit vent
à chaud c'est que x la valeur absolue de
x et pilonnent / ça veut dire que c'est
pas trop loin de x pas ça le truc dont
on peut l'écrire pour l'instant valeur
absolue de x epsilon / j'ai envie de
dire que ça c'est pas très différent de
x1
[Musique]
pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas très
différent de x1
voilà on nous conseille un or or je sais
que les gars là hein c'est que x epsilon
[Musique]
en fait faut que tout ça soit en faire
leur égard bon bref
partout n'eurent inférieure à 1
je sais qu'à distance entre x1 et x2 en
fait rien alors à un plus
qui donc a fallu que je choisis les
bonnes constante mais vrai de dire du
coup que si epsilon
du coup x nu
c'est inférieur ou égal à x taux de 8,2
hockey et du coup cela suppose que deux
plus petits comme ça
mais si les pilotes les plus petits
coeurs 1 alors et piquionne divisé là
c'est au moins de hockey lancement c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon
[Musique]
plus de deux ans que ça implique que x /
2 x + 2 est inférieure ou égale à e +2
parce que ça fait deux c4 qu'il fallait
mettre je change ma défini si oui
souvent plus que 4 + 2 + 4 ok tout ça
c'est du brouillon avant tout c'est
assez je suis fouilles ont eu quatre ça
c'est un truc que j'ai toujours voulu
faire essayer de refaire les maths en
sommes constructifs
il faut déjà lu un peu là-dessus mais je
voulais faire mauvaise passe que rigolo
on a le même argument tient alexandre +2
et donc on peut mettre ça dans cette
équation et on en déduit que s'est fixé
psylo - m6 keita est inférieur ou égal à
rip signe en plus de ne pas diviser par
2 x 1 + 4 x 2 x saaq et petit tweak
centriste plus de la l'ex en plus de 5
12 et donc c'est bien inférieur la rega
leipzig delta
yes yes
voilà donc là on a réussi à définir la
fonction iq sokkari
walou le carré est une fois où il existe
un nombre additionnel facile à calculer
et non à prouver que samedi il existe
pour les nombres réels la fonction
carrés sur les nombres réels constructif
et constructibles théorème et j'en suis
fier yes le premier était orale
ok bon et encore du chemin à faire pour
toujours rester en bas de la place on
boit on joue
ouais
ok donc ça c'est que maintenant on va
passer à des fonctions un peu plus
compliqué mais aussi définir de dériver
dans la limite d'abord un peu plus de ça
cette définition une définition est
alors le premier thérouanne et de
définition un an à définir la limite
donc non dit que limite de f1 en
fonction des genres rxl si sa définition
est évident que
pour tout et pilonnent positif
l'approximation à ypsilon près de x est
un opus epsilon parlant de l donc avec
une fonction on dit que la limite d'une
fonction en x et hey à la health it où
les approximations
[Musique]
bon allez on note t on vers l os x pour
qu'on a des lacunes quelle est sa salle
est important parce que vous parlez de
définir la dérive et en haute définition
la dérive et f x
alors quand je vais à définir de jeu
fondre la définition juste en terme de
limites je penserai plus simple
ouais à
si m
rose pas évident en fait
d'abord définir l'égalité entre de
nouveau elle n'a pas encore défini
légalité des nombres réels maintenant ça
c'est pas la bonne définition pas bonnes
donc laissé définition donc alors on dit
mme x est égal à y
si et seulement si
pour toutes les piscines positif x
l'ypsilon et devant +2 et pilonnent
epsilon assas a du sens ok c'est ok
voilà je t'ai de définir à notre truc
c'est que c'est un truc x jamais égalé
ok je vais faire nos définitions
définition x égale tilde y ce mot 40
sccm en 6x égale y pour tout epsilon xts
epsilon différent de rihanna est utile
pour effet un guerrier parce que du coup
exceptionnel jamais égal avec les
pilotes
la définition légèrement donc dit que la
limite de 100 x est elle si pour tout y
qui est égal à x mais jamais pour tout
pilote
quand est-ce que ça c'était égale
uniquement en limite légale est
uniquement à la limite je vois que j y
ai galles unis pendant la limite alors
faut-il pas besoin pour tout y est y
allé que jeunes est un trip légal c'est
trop bizarre donc le triplé galicie
assez bizarre si vous appelez jc je suis
en train de dire que de nombreux réels
peuvent être triplés gôut pas égaux face
à l'enjeu fait que j'ai défini et nombre
réel comme étant des fonctions
bon bref ça va permettre de définir
enfin la dérive et on dit que
la dérive et 2f en x et or
si et seulement si pour tous x cx
appartient à l'air tout y est galles
tilda xf1 y - l 2 x / tu y x et là c'est
cool parce que ça s'est toujours bien
défini à cause de cette hypothèse mon
propos d'epsilon tout à fait exact 6
epsilon c'était un peu trop restrictif
du coup c'est pas mal si à chaque fois
que je fais ça ça ça à temps
ces nations
[Musique]
un truc qui colle pas non plus puisqu'il
est fait
à
un beau jeu il ya un petit problème
c'est que c'est que l'alcool j'ai défini
fonction réelle une approche plus plus
raisonnable mais un peu plus classique
définir nombreux elle c'est comme des
petits pains selon la définition et à
des nombres réels qui sont différents
alors qu'ils ont la même limite décrit
le nombre réel même nombre réel donc l'
approche classique celle où deux
consciente et mais c'est chiant de
consciente et ça fout le bordel
collection t
c'est plus simple de définir un autre
sens à égalité c'est plus propre
parce qu'on en veut dire qu'en face à
ces occasions des critères d'une
fonction bien définie qu'une fonction
est bien défini ci quelle que soit la
manière de vous définit le nombre réel
pour une casse et équivalents on as
accord en fait finalement écrire ça
c'est un regret de dire qu'elle fait
continuer xrs et retard servira à
démontrer que toutes les fonctions
constructif son sang continue en ce qui
ce qui est vrai et se presser à majorer
plus plus de sens parce que là c'est
quasiment vrai par définition plus
pourquoi pas
pour tout cas est ce que la définition
un peu plus normal du coup on fait
comment les epsilon et au moins jusqu'à
quand j'étais perturbé par cette
notation mais sans excéder simplement et
on va sélectionner
[Musique]
le coût des traitements plus
rigoureusement bon rendu compte qu'un
objet elle a dérivé de l'efs ici gît les
génériques
elle est dérivée hockey
pas envie d'être creusé tout ça c'est
cool ça vous devant doutons pas seront
nessma rende le personnel
ok donc la dérive et bien définir un
prix à des fonctions un peu bizarre
c'est pas tellement des fonctions dans
ce sens on l'entend d'habitude la
fonction réelle
je pense que c'est un goût plus
constructif que d'habitude ça tue
presque même envie d'appeler sa triple
égalité hockey
le x trial f et galons x à elle le dx
trip légal elle mène 9 à d'ex trip légal
g2x
en ruine dans une note quasiment triplé
galut que trias aider haïti et là c'est
pas le même sens quadruple égal à 120
le vélv égale classique
ok ok anti anti bon définir l'intégrale
puis après c'est une autre histoire
fondamental de l'analyse à ben
maintenant sur les rails est tant mieux
est-ce que je peux prouver une
conjecture
est ce que une prime blé est égale pour
être montrées compatibilité avec le
multiplication en fait ce genre de
tornto vrai plaisir
est-ce que cuvée prix et qu'elle allait
primer v prix sacem est important
eu les primes c'est une v2 x
xdd x2 y fait y par ex on y
donc là l'idée en fait je pensais
rajouter 1 rue des ics intermédiaire de
[Musique]
xxx
on attendra bien de 8x bby
oui
[Musique]
non
c'est fini tout ça
donc là ça dit que la dérive est en fait
il faut que les approximations
excellente dérivés soit une distance
telle tad epsilon ii avait pylônes ou
delta ii epsilon fonction rationnelle
qui tend vers zéro parce que du coup
maintenant que je suis là je peux
regarder à epsilon prennent donc à
epsilon près de exceptionne savez à un
proche à epson près de lui ça va rentrer
stadistes ont pelleté de l'ypsilon tel
qu'un un pilote
[Musique]
c'est paraît-il à m c'est que
exceptionne y week end
[Musique]
pfff
ok c'est l'art de marché plus convaincu
du coup ça serait n'avoir plus que
délicat explique explicite
arrête on a quelques la dérivée de la
fonction carré
ta main aux gens ce que ses parts égales
une autre grille
une pratique de signal ici c'est pas ça
ne sort ce qui veut dire
montre que toutes les difficultés
alors quand est-ce qu'on prouve sa on a
dérivé de l'ex-quart est égal à 2 x
alors pour coup et ça
je reprends les cautions je prends y
quand j'ai noté c'est que c'était
compliqué mais c'est oublié hearn y donc
il faut que je revienne à spa à ballack
aussi qu elle soit ça on va prendre
[ __ ] c'est compliqué pensez à
découvrir pleins difficulté sur le
joueur et ses rampes facile donc on la
définit ici
qui à l'origine est en tout cas
à
en fait c'est faux
non ces définitions et les forces [ __ ]
compliqué
ah ouais je sais pourquoi c'est faux
parce qu'il faut regarder uniquement les
définitions
il faudra qu'on y est psy à messi
maintenant ce
ça serait plus facile de remplacer sa
décision qu'elle allait du coup c'est
aussi surtout plus juste
darraji de repartir de zéro c'est chiant
c'est pourquoi tâche
ouais [ __ ] c'était la deuxième
définition et la première définition les
problématiques la deuxième très
problématique de qui souhaite relancer
ou là des programmes est fou une
certaine manière a qui prennent de
rationnel non point noir et la viande
qu est ce qu il existe aussi des
fonctions à h au cul plus étoiles donc
plus sept voiles tels que xfx des
epsilon
je limite à 0 2 a racheté yala 0
[Musique]
je pense
j'ai donc fait chaque fonction est à
venir accompagné d'une fonction erreur
quand même eu la pépie france
ok
ok si je prends cette nouvelle
définition à ce que x car est bien
défini ex carré j'ai envie de dire que f
x et pilotent cette fois en douze points
en six épisodes
ok arrive et on lui impose aussi que f1
rationnelle de dégâts
est-ce qu'on me prend juste y avait
toujours une fonction de cul donc eu
plus de sens
ckx epsilon carré
et
ouais ça suffit
donc c'est plus simple ça marche au
mieux avec cette définition donc en fait
du coup là c'est en train d'essayer dans
une fonction réelle comme une tête dans
une fonction de cul donc qu on suivre
rationnelle avant tout et avec une
fonction d'erreur tel qu'il existe une
fonction des erreurs telles que la
fonction d'erreur parce qu'on lui donne
en nombre réel cette fois
donne un réel ça permet de contrôler
l'erreur entraîneur exceptionne et x
delta en particulier on sait que cette
erreur là killzone 2 x égyptienne plus
d'états tend vers zéro high tech sas
qu'ailleurs une frange extrême pétanque
est ce que ça marche maintenant donc là
j'ai réussi à définir la fonction carré
tout va bien je peux même définir son
cap fonction racine carrée remplira son
cari
et
je pense qu'il y aura des faits en
fonction à 140 0
dans l'erreur et demandera ce quart de
finale puis sera sauvegardé d'accord
c'est pas admirer nelson piquet la
silhouette de l'état
donc simon racine carrée défini c'est à
dire qu'il faudrait que pour toutes les
piscines et là j'arrive à trouver à se
garer deux pilotes
voix
reprenez tout simplifier juste définir
les fonctions il y fit
un cinquième beaucoup de hockey
alors quoi je paie ça
si on utilise de herne horaires sont
elles
c'est donc égale à sa fonction à ce
tunnel tubes tels que dai xe epsilon et
égale xlr hausse à ses peines il
ça c'est facile de shit ou cul du cul du
cul et ça se généralise totf pa plis
s'animent fixe et se généralise va avec
ft xlv exceptions comme ça c'est une
appréciation et piscine de vix est égal
à 2 x type six ans selon elle
cool beaucoup plus
action du petit à petit beaucoup de
choses que je peux pas définir la
fonction racine carrée fondation guéret
c'est très sympa fonctionner génération
carrés sur air tout entier mais surtout
temps thermale définir fonctionne car ça
s'est passé beaucoup de choses
je vais garder mes histoires de limites
quand tout fonctionne les plissés
continue trivial je communiquerai
thème destineer la fonction lice
enfin vers différents dérivés
fini les cheats dirigeable si il existe
une fonction g8 tels que roger la dérive
et
ce que vous prenez
définition j'aime bien
ce que ça c'est resté non non non ça
marche pas parce que ça définit pas les
fonctions assez horrible alors je sais
pas j'ai pas des fonctions comme le
cynisme caussinus attend
m
[Musique]
j'espérais avancé public quand même
c'est compliqué
nous
un centre vers que fonctionnant de cul
dans l'air lipszyc si à quelques côtoie
de nombreux jeunes que je donne et
quelles que soient les approximations
eyed peas après que j'appelle de guy
michael f
ces approximations et équilibrée sans
jamais plus loin que moser fois la
constante d'aller vite on dirait petit
l'onu
et
que je
r2 c'était comme culte
pour tout six
ça
ce
la précision faite de plus grande que ça
aussi après
mais bienne carré ça suffit peut-être
t
je sais pas trop si ça va marcher
si on prend la fonction car et privé ça
marche
ces trois etienne pinte avait eu 6 1
ouais
pour notre exemple maintenant
générationnel fonction de culte horaires
sont propres fonctions racine carrée par
exemple
[Musique]
bon je pense que je vais arrêter là je
vais faire une pause
tim a mijoté tout ça c'est difficile
analyse constructive encore des années
lumières du thé crime que je voulais
prouver je récupère pas définir ce qui
ne fonctionnerait selon elle lit puis je
peux sûr que sa définition se dit
souvent tu es j'avais pas définir les
dérivés de fond certains d'une manière
constructive
[Musique]
bon bah c'est d'avoir plus de chance la
prochaine fois
merci d'avoir suivi et je vais pas tant
des corps est finalement d'appartements
que ça vu à quelle force avant centre